hello everyone I'd like to show you a
game between two unknown players I
actually had this position with whites
and a lot of bullets and with games but
I never got the idea to try this
combination and I didn't think it would
work and it's a pretty one combination
for such a short game so let's see the
game b4 b5 the Scandinavian descent II
takes d5 and now nice elastic like
doesn't recapture as he doesn't wanna
lose tempo on the screen one waifu
playing Knight c3 Knight to c3 black
takes an e1 on d5 Bishop to c4 Knight to
b6 attacking the bishop Bishop to b3
nice to see six nights to f3 and now
Bishop to g4 and here y place d3 d5 and
now h3 now this h3 move is the very
important parts of this combination as
it requires the bishop to go on h5 and
you'll see why soon black plays Bishop
to h5 and white captures Knights takes
e5 allowing black captures his Queen and
if the bishop was still on g4 black
would simply take the knife which is my
stomach c6 and the night would be
protecting protecting the bishop on g4
which isn't the case now and here like
except the Queen sacrifice and it's not
a it's not a normal Queen sacrificing in
this kind of but it in this kind of
position where you know white will check
make the place blacking in a couple of
moves so here is the combination Bishop
takes f7 check King goes three seven
Bishop to g5 check King's have to go to
d6 only move and now a wife doesn't want
to recapture the Queen because still
Kemp will be down a piece so
White has the figure I've had to
continue this attack and as well he does
he plays 94 trick given up another piece
so King takes on e5 and now f4
the King has to go to be for only me and
here why simply requesting two captures
the bishop and d1 and here white is
threatening to place King eetu and after
King D to the quantity three checkmate
and like to get the subject somehow he
could try a lot of things
capturing the bishop and g5 doesn't help
the best try would probably Bishop to b4
check but the black found another way to
stop King Jesus so he played King
betrayed himself and here white castles
now the thread is root 2 e 1 check and
quantity 3 checkmate and now black plays
nice to d4 and the idea is after rook e1
check he will try to go 92 and the
cover-up so we have root D 2 e 1 check
that goes 3-2 and price simply captures
it rook takes it to check King has take
and our bishop @ h5 check can catch the
low to e3 rook to f3 check King goes the
d4 only move and now it seems like like
black game is safe and keeping just the
most out of there through d5 and c6 and
this is the move that saves the game for
wife Bishop to f7 and now there is
nothing black can do there is no move he
can play whatever he does it's checkmate
like fries with the Knight to d5 but
this only prolongs the game for two
moments
c3 check nice has to take only move
and here white captures the knight on c3
which checkmate so this is a very short
game only 22 moves and it's very long
combination is actually 11 moves to this
check made from the time black captured
white screen and d1 and what's more
interesting about this game is that
white could capture blacks Queen for 11
weeks and still the he didn't there was
always something of the play there was a
way to force checkmate in all variations
so yeah this is the game this is the
thrill of the hunt I hope you enjoyed it
and see you soon
hopefully maybe you can remember it and
maybe it'll come in handy too in your
wits and dollar games say system